sur ce plateau je reçois présent aurélie
brard bonsoir du club face de saint
quentin en yvelines à vos côtés
christophe jean moulin bonsoir voila du
collège gustave-courbet attrape juste en
face de vous l'une de vos élèves
l'ajustement de cet établissement window
bonsoir à toi effet olivier boulanger
bonsoir vous êtes du technocentre
renault à guyancourt vous êtes tous les
quatre impliqué dans ce dispositif des
collégiens de trappes qui sont en
immersion au technocentre
le projet est baptisé classe en
entreprise vous allez nous le détail et
dans un instant auparavant je vous le
disais en titre elle les chiffres du
chômage dans le département une
situation qui devient de plus en plus
compliqué plus 2,3 pour cent c'est
l'augmentation du nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi dans les yvelines en un mois un
chiffre en plus forte croissance qu'au
niveau national où le taux de chômage a
progressé de 1,4 pour cent les yvelines
reste toutefois un département encore
épargnée avec un taux global de chômage
qui s'élève à 7% à comparer aux 10,5
pour cent de la france le département
dans sa partie nord en vallée de seine
souffre notamment de baisses d'emplois
dans l'industrie automobile à saint
quentin en yvelines certaines communes
sont préservés comme guyancourt
ici dans cette agence six mille offres
d'emploi sont proposées par an et le
taux de chômage est similaire à
l'allemagne 5 5% pour le directeur de
pôle emploi yvelines est la situation
dans le département commencent à se
tendre
on est sur une situation où
on a plutôt une baisse des sorties de la
demande d'emploi on n'a pas eu de
croissance significative des
inscriptions sur le mois de janvier
par contre il est compliqué aujourd'hui
plus compliqué de retrouver un emploi
sur les douze premiers mois de l'année
le taux de chômage a progressé de 11%
dans le département les yvelines compte
environ 50 mille demandeurs d'emploi on
va s'intéresser à présent cette
initiative originale justement autour de
l'emploi et de la formation avec ces
collégiens on l'évoquait juste avant ce
reportage
on va vous demander justement quelques
précisions helibras réalisatrice du
projet pour l'antenne phase de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la fondation
agir contre l'exclusion en quoi consiste
ce projet classe en d'entreprise alors
ce projet consiste à immerger pendant
trois jours une classe d'élèves de 3e
dans l'entreprise technocentre renault à
guyancourt
le principe fait que les élèves ont des
cours qui sont co construit avec un
salarié et leurs enseignants habituels
donc ce sont des matières une matière
comme la technologie correspond à un
cours qui est donnée par le
professionnel à sa son service son
secteur d'activité et ensuite ça
consiste vraiment à une rencontre en
fait entre entre les élèves et les
professionnels du technocentre l'idée
c'est de mener un projet concret a
véritablement on est au delà du cours en
amphithéâtre on va dire du cours
magistral tout à fait c'est de façon à
donner une application concrète des
cours que des élèves peuvent recevoir
ordinairement dans le milieu
professionnel de leur donner du sens en
fait une classe entière ils participent
à ce dispositif 24 24 élèves 24
d'ailleurs notre chiffre du jour parmi
ces différents collégiens du collège
courbes et attrapes goundo comment ça se
passe pour toi actuellement
je suis en 3e au collège gustave courbet
et ce dispositif pour ckoi et comment ça
s'est déroulé depuis depuis lundi est ce
que ça a été quelque chose de positif
véritablement pour toi oui non ça nous a
permis de découvrir plusieurs métiers et
de savoir que derrière une voiture il ya
plusieurs métiers et la demande est
justement un temps professeur comment ça
s'est passé pour ces élèves c'est
quelque chose de concret qui l'ont
découvert voilà sortis de
l'établissement pour aller au contact de
professionnels
tout à fait je vais je vais je vais
rajouter que ce que madame brady ça
donne du sens à l'école derrière
derrière beaucoup de métier il ya des il
ya des matières scolaires
le plus bel exemple a été ce matin ils
ont refait un court quasiment de de
physique avec l'électricité les tensions
les puissances est tous assez mais même
en techno je fais aussi ce genre de
manipulation et c'est vrai que ça donne
du sens et pour moi en tant de fois en
court et voit pas forcément
certainement pour autant ça sert ensuite
dans la vie professionnelle comme
ingénieur il refait en quelque sorte en
collaboration avec le professeur le
court ils sont un petit peu surpris mais
c'est vrai quand ils ont été beaucoup
plus attentifs que ce qu'on a beau
habiter dans une salle de cours bon faut
dire qu'ils étaient bien encadrés cinq
ou six adultes dans une salle on n'était
là que pour eux et forcément ils ont eu
un comportement excellent enfin très
bien au niveau de la terre est au niveau
de la participation
mais pour être professeur enfin moi moi
je sais que c'est pas la première fois
que j'en suis pas mon premier galop
d'essai ça fait cinq six ans que je
travaille notamment avec le club fasse
comme je dis c'est mon actionnaire
principal à travers des projets comme la
graine d'entreprises à travers des
visites d'entreprises le forum aussi
entreprise ça fait six ans gilles
travaillait c'est vrai que c'est très
utile pour les pour les pour les élèves
et je pense que ça leur permet de se
projeter un peu plus dans l'avenir a
justement ça a suscité une vocation chez
toi dorénavant tu sais où tu vas
travailler ce que tu veux faire je
compte me diriger dans une école
d'ingénieurs
être ingénieur en bâtiment en
bâtiment se sera pas dans l'automobile
malgré tout on va demander justement du
côté de renault calce quel est l'intérêt
d'un tel projet olivier boulanger à
l'intérêt de montre en tout cas quand il
ya eu cette initiative de la fondation
face renault a été tout de suite
partante
parce que ça fait partie des noms des
partenaires enfin renault l'un des
partenaires de phase ii puni tellement
l'origine voilà tout à fait tout à fait
ça fait partie du dispositif vis à vis
de la jeunesse
c'est vrai que par rapport aux jeunes en
alternance les stagiaires les
dispositifs qu'on peut avoir à que
l'anpe ou des missions locales
ça faisait partie du dispositif qui
permet justement d'avoir un
rapprochement aux jeunes et la finalité
de dire donner un peu de visibilité aux
jeunes par rapport à leurs études et ou
métiers depuis y avoir sachant que chez
renault a la chance d'avoir un éventail
très large de métier du coup les
différents collaborateurs renault avec
les professeurs qui ont pu travailler
sur ses différents métiers ont pu donner
des éclairages différents aux jeunes
comme une d'eau et du coup ça leur a
permis de découvrir des tas de métiers
qu'ils soupçonnaient pas dans
l'automobile et si la prochaine fois
c'est dans une entreprise de btp
khudobin ce sera avec grand plaisir mais
on va trouver l'initiative en tout cas
très très intéressante
ça vous permet aussi peut-être du côté
de renault on va parvenir des
difficultés économiques actuelles de
l'entreprise même des difficultés de
l'emploi au niveau national mais de
montrer aussi que vos professions sont
utiles ils servent à quelque chose et il
ya des malgré tout on l'espère ensuite
des débouchés sur ses différentes
filières il ya de la boue j'ai bien sûr
et puis la situation qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui il faut espérer qu'elle
mesurait d'isolation actuelle on
l'espère al akili des dix élèves de 3e
c'est pour dans cinq ou six ans donc là
si on est vraiment aux projections de 2
2% par ce dispositif là donc
effectivement on est on lancera sur
l'avenir on n'aurait pas sûr sur
l'actuelle qu'effectivement il dit la
seconde affiche effectivement plus plus
compliqué pour la situation actuelle
quel bilan vous pouvez faire de
l'opération l'a débuté lundi sa tâche
mais aujourd'hui tout simplement pour
ces 24 jeunes qui ont participé quel
bilan vous en faites pas un bilan assez
positif je pense que ça a été mais
restait dans le sens où ça a permis à
deux mondes de se rencontrer et que
chacun ait conscience de la réalité de
de la personne qu'il a pu rencontrer en
fait j'imagine que pour pour les élèves
ils ont dû rencontrer donc des
ingénieurs donc ça veut dire des
personnes à un niveau d'étude assez
élevé c'est avec un niveau de vie sains
une réalité sociale qui peut être
différente de ce qu'ils peuvent
connaître chez eux ça c'est une première
réalité
et puis ensuite pour les professionnels
aussi de d'être en contact direct avec
avec ces jeunes de mais d'approcher leur
culture et puis leurs cadres
d'aujourd'hui vous allez ouvrir le
dispositif à d'autres entreprises
après cette expérience en tout cas
réussi ce sera pas trop difficile pour
les élèves de retourner en cours
maintenant je n'ose y penser il ya les
vacances et bientôt une pierre à
quelques jour là il y aura encore des
souvenirs je pense à la des traces à la
rentrée mais c'est vrai que je confirme
ce que dit mon âme rares par rapport à
on al'intention au collège de se
projeter ce projet sur un niveau donc
sur des élèves de 4e ou 3e mais c'est
vrai que le niveau 3e pour est
intéressant parce que tous les élèves de
france et de navarre en troisième il
doit faire un stage d'une semaine en
entreprise et pouvoir passer quelques
jours en entreprise dans une entreprise
comme renault et d'autres ça permet ben
que celui que l'élève cas pas de chance
87 âge moyen dans une entreprise qui
l'intéressent pas forcément alors que là
il sera appliqué à la vie de
l'entreprise voilà tout à fait ça
apporte beaucoup plus de choses
positives est beaucoup plus aussi de
réflexion parce que un élève qui va
emballer qui va emballer des objets
pendant une semaine je dis pas que c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas positif parce
que peut-être qu'il en a tiré quelque
chose mais pouvoir voir plusieurs
métiers plusieurs personnes qui leur
part de leur métier sont là que pour eux
un vrai suivi avec
saignant aussi puisque c'est un projet
qui implique l'ensemble des acteurs en
l'occurence renaud ce collège courbet
avec les enseignants les élèves et le
club face qui était à l'origine merci
donc à tous les quatre je vous précise
que nous reviendrons sur ce dispositif
classe en entreprise dans l'actuelle
toute l'image de la rédaction rendez
vous dès 20h30 pour découvrir le
reportage de claire cambier et de l'audi
moines dont vous avez d'ailleurs vu les
images au cours de cette séquence sur le
plateau merci à vous depuis le début de
la semaine une partie des usagers de la
sncf vivre un enfer des trajets plus
longs en raison de l'incendié d'un poste
technique et le trafic est interrompu
pour deux à trois semaines sur la ligne
la verrière la défense quelques
réactions compilées par catherine zola
tôt et le diwan un message d'information
qui défilent des agents en gilet rouge
pour renseigner les voyageurs
depuis la fermeture de la ligne entre la
verrière et la défense pour des raisons
techniques
les usagers doivent faire preuve de
patience et il en faut mais dix habitent
plus tôt et bien travailler à saint
quentin en yvelines
avant c'était six stations et 45 minutes
aujourd'hui c'est le double je prends le
tramway t2 jusqu'à issy val ciel puis le
rer c et jusqu'à saint quentin en
yvelines
déjà c'est celle en 45 minutes c'est
long maintenant c'est x 2 donc
vivre avec à la descente du train
toujours des agents pour renseigner et
toujours le même message que l'on peut
entendre entre versailles et quand il
est interrompue
je suis
ils se sont même drôlement améliorée au
niveau de la communication
ça fait une trentaine d'années chemin et
transportant des informations claires
précises qui temporise l'agacement les
avis rencontrer ce soir
bonjour cependant je m'inquiète je sais
pas réellement les dégâts clients oui
c'est vrai que c'est important france
alors maintenant on peut se poser des
questions c'est pas pour ça que ça va
changer les choses
d'autres trouvent des parades comme ceux
par exemple qui viennent de loin pour
garder leurs petits enfants le mercredi
un an je suis obligée d'entrer mercredi
soir et ça pénalise un peu mes enfants
parce que c'est eux qui sont obligés de
déposer enfants à la crèche et ce alors
ça les met pas en avance en tête la
ligne vue devrait rester interrompu
pendant encore deux semaines un trafic
stoppée en raison d'un incendie survenu
au poste de signalisation de
sèvres-ville d'avray
la sncf propose quatre itinéraires de
substitution soit en passant par issy
val de seine soit par la ligne paris
montparnasse